foreign  I'm sorry I had to leave early did I  mention you look beautiful this movie  every time you buy pastries it costs us  money  we'll take it for my salary  you forget to own the company  is that so  Mrs John beanie called  who is champindy  she is unhappy with that tractor  she is unhappy with tonino she's his  teacher  you have to spend more time with him I  give him everything yes you give him  money clothes cars but of yourself  and that's what he really wants  you know he is as smart as you are but  he's failing  I'll talk to him  my friend Diego has a new exhibit  I hate your friend Diego  go bring to Nino spend some time  together as a family